who had to put a big influence on you
beside your fight you had to see a fight
and say hey
i want to be like that
you know what
it was muhammad ali really that's the
fighter who i saw and i said
i want to be like him and not just him
inside the ring but like
him all around like i want to be as
confident as him i want to go so pretty
much you want to be an activist
yeah yeah
muhammad ali um when i was he's the most
confident fighter that ever lived
you know i studied him a lot and um most
of his fighting as he got a little old
absolute um psychology you know i'll
leave a box at the bottom you would
never think you know what if they hate
him ali be in the clinch talking about
their mother screaming their mother and
sister would i caught your sister around
the truck and i fed this and ali is the
most disgusting person when he's in the
ring fighting he's saying things so bad
the referee said i just can't even tell
you what he was saying i never thought
he would do that he didn't look like
that
they're talking about screwing this
person in your family and this and that
and joe frazier said what kind of man is
like that who does that you know and
that's just who he was he was a
psychology he fought like you know he
had he got to a certain age where he
wasn't as fast as he was and so he used
a lot of psychology i think that boxing
had a lot to do with out to egos because
we're not who we are
inside the ring outside the ring
you can fight without the ego
that part
you can fight this is an interesting
thing
that um you can learn right now
we need the ego to fight we need the ego
to succeed we need the ego because the
ego is just protecting us they believe
but um
what happens um
you know when the ego is out of control
we all go through that part when they go
out of control we think we're more than
what we are the ego is only an illusion
that controls us in some states just an
illusion doesn't exist
but we make it exist and for making that
ego exist we accomplish really great
things
but it's only an illusion
and that on something that doesn't have
no existence can make something real
[Music]